having been in sales for over 20 years
one of the things I can tell you SMO
speaker the first two weeks of January
the first two weeks of the year they're
dry they don't have people to said they
don't have clients and they're wondering
oh my gosh what do I do I'm starting off
dry I don't have anybody to talk to the
reason for it is because in the month of
December one of the best months ever to
establish new clients to get new
customers to get new referrals the month
of December they don't do their part to
prepare themselves to kick off to your
strong today I'm gonna share with you
how you can get ten customers during the
holidays so before I get into it I want
to preface something here's the fact
that in the month of December it depends
what industry you're part of meaning you
could be car sales and you got good
things going on during car sales but you
could be in real estate and you may not
be selling them real estate I mean
insurance we always have big December's
because over the years I listen to so
many of my competitors automatically
saying December is a terrible month
December is a terrible month December is
a terrible month until they believed it
and I said December is a great month why
because everybody gets together
everybody's in a pretty happy mood
because it's holidays and they kind of
want to talk and they're a little bit
more open they're a little bit more fun
friendly because it's good season the
music the whole thing makes you feel
good that is the time where you go get
new customers so for example may give me
an idea what I used to do as a rookie
salesperson year one six months year two
three four five
I still do this every Christmas every
December and I was always stacked in a
month of general with clients and the
time when I didn't do it general is a
rough month for me first thing I used to
do make a list of names of places you go
to regularly what do I mean by this Jim
same place Geoffrey Loop same place a
restaurant seven restaurants you go to
you know the three Starbucks you go to
the dealership you go to whatever office
you go to whatever place you go get your
haircut whatever place you go for your
laundry for your dry cleaning for your
Sunday church for whatever you anything
it is make a list of all the places you
go to next at all these places make a
list of first names you don't need last
names first names of who you know at
this place like a Jim Bobbie Jackie
Larry
okay great so I know at 24 Hour Fitness
I know Bobbie Jackie Larry great I write
those names down I know at the Starbucks
place I go to the manager's name was a
Cindy I always get along with Cindy
she's always good to me great when I go
to this restaurant the hostess at the
front of this Ruth's Chris restaurant
Charlie he's connected he's been there
for a few years he's always good
I want this guy so you make a list so
one places you go to number two under
each place you go to you tie the names
of people that you know at these places
the next thing you do with that is you
make a list of five creative gifts what
I mean by creative gifts I like to add
humor to it but add some kind of a
creative gift and maybe a popcorn
machine
it may be bottles of wine it may be a
certain humor thing that you're gonna
give to somebody that they're gonna
laugh there's so many cool unique gifts
to find out there's us less than $10 or
less than $20 but you make a list of all
these creative gifts that's five gifts
make a list of your top 50 best clients
you have I'm talking to your best
clients that you do business with these
are people they have a relationship with
these are people that you call they're
gonna pick up these are people that
you've met two three four five times
they love you you love them great
relationship depending on the business
you're in maybe you're a real estate you
don't have 50 clients maybe you got top
ten best clients
maybe you got top 20 best clients but
whatever it is somewhere between 10 or
50 clients if you're in something that's
more transactions go to fifth the next
thing you know once you have the list of
names the following this is the big part
you get your car you have your gift one
buy one buy when you go to these places
okay and I would literally do this I
would go to these places and I will go
up now and say hey Charlie I got a
bottle of wine for you oh really yeah
Merry Christmas man
all the best brother you're always good
oh thanks bro hey Mary this is for you I
got a book for you I hope you enjoyed
this book oh thank you so much
hey and everybody I'm give him an a note
and a envelope with my notes and my card
in it here so I am and I leave in my
information I already have their
information there right I'm leaving all
these things and locally while I'm
networking with them then I go to my
customers hey got something for you
here's a pie oh no way I got a pound one
drop something off to her you at the
house yes I'm coming over then I would
go the Kia's face-to-face to drop these
things off when they see you this is the
first thing they're thinking about so
now
say you've done it to twenty places you
go to and you got twenty names there
that you do do it to say you've done it
to 50 clients that you have and this
takes you day and a half to do right
they you have 70 names of people net
that are saying wait a minute nobody
else did this for me my other real
estate guy didn't do this for me my
other insurance person didn't do this
for me
maha the finance person didn't do this
for me this other prick none of these
guys did it for me and maybe some of
these guys are even cold people like man
nobody else did it for me I've been
going through this restaurant I've been
working for two years
no one's ever stopped stopped by and
giving me a gift I've been at this gym
for two and a half years no one's ever
dropped off a gift to me so now you have
a group of 70 new true believers of you
who want to find a way to help you
without you asking for help yet so this
is one of the things you do right now
see there's a follow up you go back with
them but this is part one let me give
you part two what you do part two what
you do is you make a list of your top
best contacts that you have in business
who are also in sales they could be
selling consulting legal CPA accountant
it doesn't matter insurance real estate
finance you make a list of twenty of
these guys okay once you make a list of
twenty of these guys you figure out a
way to send them customers you figure
out a way to send them contacts and then
you say hey I know it's holiday season I
was thinking about the two of you guys
Bobby and Larry I just think it makes us
for the two of you guys to talk to one
another in two texts you say Bobby I
know him from you know he's one of the
local real estate guys I know I'm very
well good guy and Jack you know you and
I used to work out together but Jack I
know you were talking about you're
thinking about doing something with real
estate if you decide to do anything
Bobby's the guy to go through next I'm
doing 20 contacts potential customers
with 20 business people and I'm making
the connection now whether any of these
guys do business with these 20 guys
guess what these 20 guys are thinking
about these 20 guys are thinking about
who else did this for me
this guy send me customers are you
kidding me well thank you on a separate
message John you didn't have to do this
man thank you they're surprised you just
did this because how many people have
ever done it to you think about it ask
the question how many people have sent a
customer to you without anything in
return how many people have done it to
you actually think about it for yourself
exactly why it's so effective because
nobody sends like it's not a common
thing that happens during holidays but
you're doing it that separates you from
everybody else next thing host a holiday
party and invite all your business guys
together invite your customers that you
already do business with and host a
holiday party at your office put a
potluck together do something fun and
invite everybody food fun networking
get-together no outcome how's everything
how you doing how's the family how's
this how's that every single time either
put a party together in my office or I
put a party together on my house and I
invited clients or associates or people
that I know you know what happened every
single time every single time every time
I got customers every single time I got
business from it without even asking for
it that would invite people over I used
to do barbecues every Tuesday night for
god knows how many years and I would
cook for people cook for people business
would show our business would show our
business would show up all the time but
these moments during the holiday when
you do this other people aren't doing it
again you're creating your database and
more data of clients that are coming
back to do business with you in 2020 and
last but not least there's something to
be thinking about by the way there are
50 other things you could be doing this
is on you to be creative during season
like this by sitting down and testing
different methods I've tested thousands
of different ways to go out there and
create campaigns to get new customers
many of them have failed but many of
them I've used to put fish bowls and I
would go put 40 fish bowls out 40
different laundry mats within a 20 mile
radius and I would say I'm gonna give
$10 every month
$20 gift card every month but allow
people to drop gift cards in here every
month I sent a $20 gift card to your
customers are you okay with that yeah
sure great here's a fishbowl and I buy
$20 gift card to have that real estate
they don't have a problem I go collect
them boom next boom collect them next
and I would there's so many ways to do
it here's the last thing whatever you're
doing your language social media
whatever you're doing everybody on
social media wants to go and get the
guys that got a million followers a half
a million followers 150,000 followers
and get them to win them over right
there is a sweet spot of people with
influencers that you can help that are
between
thousand to twenty thousand followers
thousand to fifty thousand followers who
are not getting hundreds of messages
that your message being lost in
translation if you find the people that
have five to fifty thousand followers
and you've been following them and you
say Bobby love you contact that's once
you know how can I help you and you go
based on hashtag of local business
owners in your area twenty mile radius
I go hashtag Tarzana California I go
hashtag whatever the areas are and then
I find a local influencers right I am
messaging them hey love with you what
the work you're doing here's what I do
how can I help you how can I help you
I've been saying this for years on how
can I help you here's why when you go to
somebody at a coffee shop and they're
standing they sit right next to them
let's just say they're having a cup of
coffee they say man I like your shirt
no thanks but what do you do by the way
I'm a real estate what do you think
they're gonna ask you what do you do
okay you ask your peers on social media
hey man I know holiday season is here
how can I help you how can I help you I
got big plans in 2020 but I want to ask
you Paul how can I help you oh you know
here's what I'm looking for is there any
context that let me know if I can help
you with this yeah here's an area two
out of ten towns guess what they're
gonna say how can I help you oh great
you ask here's what I'm doing this the
business I'm in and here's what I'm
looking for and give them a specific
detailed not general I'm looking for new
clients nope you know thanks I'm glad
you asked I'm looking for folks between
30 to 40 years old who are working at a
job making six figures or maybe people
who got laid off and they're looking at
rolling over or folks that are between
35 to 55 years old Mary that are
thinking about upgrading to another
house or I'm looking to my whatever your
niche is that I'm looking for a business
owner that doesn't do digital media or
social media that wants you give them
that niche and then they go to work and
they may tell you it's me or somebody
else or they give you a referral
regardless everything I said to you you
could test one of them and it could
possibly not work for you but eventually
one of them will and by the time January
first comes along you got a stack of 20
30 40 50 clients to call and if you can
close a good percentage of them you got
10 new clients in a month of January to
kick off your year and these are one of
the ways I just
with you a few different ways these are
some of the ways you can get 10 clients
during holiday season having said that I
got two other videos I want you to watch
one of them is a video I did years ago I
think three years ago four years ago
titled how to network like Casanova if
you haven't watched it click over here
and the other one is since Christmas is
around the corner New Year's around the
corner I did this video I want to say
five years ago maybe titled uh four
years ago titled how to overcome your
limiting beliefs and this video was done
at the end of New Year's at the end of
the year in December and we're like a
red sweater whatever you do don't miss
the last eight minutes of this video
it's the last eight minutes of the video
that you really got to watch obviously
go through it but the last eight minutes
in the video is the main part you want
to watch with this video either wanted
them click on them and if you haven't
subscribed yet please do so take
everybody bye-bye
[Music]